E hoje nós vamos testar o boneco mais
indestrutível da internet o boneco
indestrutível mister musculo eu posso
ficar o ao máximo eu vou usar martelo eu
vou usar a sério vou usar várias
ferramentas e principalmente vamos
utilizar o nosso Leite super potente
pessoal fiquei até o fim assistir ouvir
e partilham com um amigo é ser muito
like e bora lá pessoal aqui quem fala é
o Dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e eu hoje trago-vos aqui o que
vocês tanto pedem nós vamos ter aqui uma
experiência então é mais clientes têm
mais um teste né Nós temos aqui o nosso
boneco conhecer um osco uô pronto só
primeiro passo Vamos abrir aqui nosso
brinquedo Ok espero que daqui é muito
conhecido por cálculo vocês já devem ter
visto aqui no YouTube e eu também já fiz
um vídeo na presença atentares uma galo
acho que eu consegui na altura mas era o
estarmos como muito Pequenino então este
é o grande Este é o original Bora lá
testar eu não tenho nunca tivesse boneco
em casa ok é
e não é gigante em comparação ao outro
muito gigante Manda aí para o pé e
se divertir eu fui ali que a criança que
não tivesse em casa eu também não teria
isso é muito eu adoro aqui na altura
Havia uns monstrinhos tu apertava sim
sair os olhos vamos quem gosta mas não é
outra coisa que é o nosso me espera
músculo famoso Arnold de brinquedo arma
não sei se é verdade né é instrutivo
instrutivo buscar chovendo você vem aqui
vocês podem torcer pode explicar o
o podem ver tenho aqui a minha doença e
uma caixa de ferramentas Aqui tá o
martelo tenho que estas pinças temos
aqui um alicate uma serra ou meu Deus
não a chave pessoal já deixa muito like
aqui nesse vídeo ok Não mas antes eu
gostava de fazer aqueles teste daquele
teste básico quer esticar ao máximo
e bora fazer o meu Deus Ai tomara que eu
vou morrer eu sou eu
é bem festa marcada pode estar aqui o pé
primeiro aquele disse quando a força de
muito rápido ele meio que a pessoa pode
se eu tocar assim é bem fácil enfiar o
dedo eu fico mole mas se eu bater com
força pessoal ele não vai para dentro aí
agora foi a alma acalma seu mistério nos
continentes muito a sério mas isso é só
Ok vamos bater com essa parte de uma
delas publica muito mais coisa agora 32
do leite é pa abriu um
E no meio ó o final mais resistente o
martelo martelo uma lâmina a espada do
Samurai estava não isso aqui a cabeça
juro vocês abre aqui já abriu como é que
tá as garotas gastar quase calma calma
calma eu não passou no teste do Martelo
Mas eu também com esta ponta né Vamos lá
dançar hora das pintas logo de uma vez
já sabia ai eu escutei meu forte Olha aí
a resistiu às vezes ter Alencar
eu fiz um buraco eu acho que não tem
tacto tacto que está aqui o pé eu vou
ficar com toda a força possível
o impacto Ok passou aperto um alicate
pessoal acham que havia de estar já a
terra não sei mas se o martelo abriu o
senhor muscular pega também vai abrir
pode estar aqui no pé só 5 letra
já saiu já cortei 3 vezes olha Vejam Só
acho Leia que sai daqui devido a Isto é
diferente Isto é tipo uma cola mesmo
fiquei para ver até o fim porque no
final eu vou abrir todo homem músculo e
vamos utilizar esta partida toda para
brincar aqui um pouco eu fiquei até o
fim ok Aqui está o nosso dar do que está
preparado agora é só carregar uns aqui
nesse botão e o dar é que lançado como a
velocidade gigante Ok mas não estar aqui
com esta caixa 10213 passou a caixa por
ou aqui tá Aqui o buraco e ainda foram
Alcatraz Então já sabemos que ela é
forte e bora lá testar então outra o
senhor músculos hahaha óculos de
proteção então acaba acaba não esquecer
a entrar no olho Ai meu Deus 321 então
era aí senhor músculos da barriga 3211
o escritor um mamilo e não entrou
incrível estás a ver eu entrei mas sai
logo não é chega a furar alguma que
entrou aqui e outra da sobrancelha tá
ali outra e outra aqui na orelha meu
Deus 37 shot e as que entraram aqui no
peito nem sequer abrir o buraco a espera
abriu sim abre assim abriu Olha aí
bom então tira o dedo aqui por trás e
pra sair Olha aí entrou aqui sim ele
furou para encontrar aqui a sair um
material viscoso Olha aí então temos
dois golpes um dos abdominais e um amigo
vai lá pessoal vamos estar aqui laser
super potente que eu já comprei há algum
tempo OK eu já fiz um vídeo com este
laser fiz laser vs iPhone iPhone não
acho que não tem podes né aí o vídeo e
se quiserem ver se nunca viram que este
letra é muito mas muito potente em
comparação as letras que eu já tenho
usado aqui no canal
é uma corrente Olha aí é mesmo tipo de
eletricidade do poste lá pipoca não é
pneus não é brincadeira mesmo muito
forte Ok só para vocês terem uma noção
da potência do laser vejam como é que
ele bate aqui no armário Olha aí é muito
forte nem consigo olhar agora sim é o
verdadeiro teste agora que você já viram
a potência do laser ok
a bola pessoal mister musculo está
pronto agora vou utilizar a nossa coisa
agora tá muito potente Eu até tenho aqui
uma ventoinha que é para refrigerar Ok
olhos é super potente do versus homem
músculo em 3 2 1 vai
E aí a próxima a próxima está a passar
alguma coisa
um acordo alguma coisa que já tá ser
fumaça tá sempre massa tá não tá
quem sabe ter o plástico Já pensei assim
queimar Olha eu passei por 11
é mas olha aí ó
o seu apelo
E se o seu as 6 toda aí perfurou o
senhor músculo
e nem só vamos lá aproximar perto das
cuecas dele agora três vezes não vai
Ah tá tem muita fumaça aqui queima muito
aqui tá a queimar a queimar e vem quando
é continuar defunto
e o meu Deus está fazer um buraco nessa
[Música]
e não pronto a próxima a próxima olha aí
ó
e eu vou aproximar ainda mais Olha só
cama muito assim de perto vamos testar
aqui na cabeça dele no Olho no Olho
e olha isso Meu não é nada que resista a
este laser meu é incrível
E aí ficou com olho preto e
o Ok vou deixar aqui algum tempo
E aí
e cheira muito mal é que eu vou lá ver o
pintado de preto
E aí
E isto é caso para dizer pessoal que o
nosso essa venceu o mister musculo Ok
vamos ver o que é que tem por dentro do
ministério rosto
é o mesmo só pessoal que ele tem por
dentro Olha isso é uma geleia muito
pegajosa meu Olha isso
eu não sei se eu consigo arrancar tudo o
que tem por dentro não é
e Vejam só pessoal tá assim tudo pelo
que tinha na perna e
e esta Cola é forte o suficiente tem
quase certeza para levantar esta mesma
escola 8 olha aí olha aqui embaixo
também se levanta toda ó ó
a mesma pessoa vamos ficar por aqui com
esse vídeo Espero que tenham gostado já
sabem mandei este vídeo Um dos vossos
amigos lá no WhatsApp envia o link para
ele e não desligou nada ok deixei lá ele
tranquilaça ver um vídeo que é isso
deixa muito like já sabem se quiserem
ver mais experiências deste gênero aqui
no canal comentem aí também e é isso
Pessoal espero que tenham gostado fiquem
bem e até a